- Hey guys, I'm Gary Vaynerchuk.
♫ Gary Vee ♫
- [Voiceover] Gary Vaynerchuk
is a fast-talking,
irreverent, business
guru who calls himself
a serial entrepreneur.
- I'm a businessman.
Entrepreneur.
I'm a four-time New York Times bestseller.
I'm a guy that loves to give keynotes.
No shit, your product (bleep) blows.
(bleep) you, nerd.
Stop watching (bleep) Lost.
You need to bet on your strengths
and don't give a (bleep)
about what you suck at.
Yeah, I curse a little bit.
Would you (bleep) subscribe?
And on this channel you're gonna get
my two core shows.
The #AskGaryVee Show!
- Hi, Gary.
Hello, Gary Vee.
- Hey Gary, it's Mark Cuban.
- On this episode, I have a guest.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
And Daily Vee.
I'm turning into a 14-year-old girl.
- Hey it's, I don't want
to interrupt you guys.
- [Gary] Two minutes.
- Yeah, do your thing.
- What, you got bills to pay?
- I just don't understand
these deductions, man.
- How are ya?
We're puttin' out real
fire, this shit is intense.
And if you subscribe right now.
Subscribe, now!
You're gonna make me so goddamned happy.
So email me at Gary@Vaynermedia.
Not later, right now.
You would make my life so
happy.